bueno muchas muchas gracias muchas
gracias es un gran honor tenerles acá
hoy vamos a presenciar
el mayor y el más malvado abuso de poder
en la historia de este país estamos
viendo a un presidente corrupto
haciendo y deteniendo a su oponente
político
cargos bajo los cuales él y otros
presidentes serían culpables justo antes
de una elección presidencial en la cual
él va a perder
esto se llama interferencia electoral y
es otro intento para robar esta elección
presidencial pero mucho más importante
es una persecución política es algo
salido de una nación fascista o
comunista este día quedará en la infamia
será recordado por siempre no solamente
con el presidente más corrupto en la
historia de nuestro país sino
posiblemente
incluso más importante el presidente que
junto con una banda de sus maleantes más
cercanos en marxistas también trataron
de destruir la democracia estadounidense
Pero ellos fracasarán incluso ganaremos
mucho más de lo que lo hemos ganado
antes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
acusar a un expresidente de los Estados
Unidos bajo el acta de espionaje de 1917
Ese no era el propósito o un acto por un
crimen tan detestable que solamente la
pena de muerte sería suficiente
amenazarme con 400 años en prisión por
tener mis propios papeles presidenciales
así como cualquier otro presidente es
una de las cosas más descaradas una
teoría terrible de las más terribles que
se ha presentado las Cortes
estadounidenses el acta de espionaje ha
sido usada para perseguir traidores
espías y no tiene nada que ver con un
expresidente que mantiene legalmente sus
propios documentos como presidente de la
ley que aplica a este caso
no es la ley de espionaje sino
simplemente
el acta de registros presidenciales que
ni siquiera está mencionada en esta
acusación ridícula de 44 páginas bajo el
acta de registro presidenciales que es
civil no es criminal yo tenía todo
derecho de tener estos documentos
esto se ha demostrado el caso más
importante hasta el momento es el caso
Clinton Sox
Clinton apesta sabe lo que significa
cierto después deja la Casa Blanca
Bill Clinton quedó con varias cintas de
audio en
una de sus gavetas incluía discusiones
de ejército estadounidense el rol en
Haití discusiones sobre la política
extranjera de Estados Unidos en defensa
y en ofensiva en Cuba grabaciones del
presidente Clinton y sus grabaciones
con todos los líderes extranjeros en ese
momento piensen en eso datos sensibles
sobre la exposiciones de comercio
información de presidenciales
discusiones con el secretario de estado
sobre conflicto en Bosnia mucho más son
cosas muy importantes y no solamente
Bill Clinton nunca fue considerado para
una acusación criminal basados en las
cintas que él tomó sino que cuando fue
demandado ganó el caso
la juez tomó esa decisión y dice que
bajó el esquema estatutorio establecido
por el acta de registro presidenciales
la decisión de segregar El material
personal del registro presidencia es el
estomada por el presidente
durante el término presidencial
y en
bajo la discreción completa del
presidente le sorprende escuchar eso
cierto cualquier administración normal
inclusive incluyendo una administración
opositoria podría decir que eso es el
final y ya pero no la administración de
biden que es corrupta
la decisión de las medias como es
conocida también declara que los
archivos nacionales
de estas administraciones no tiene la
autoridad de Designar material como como
registro presidenciales no tiene la
autoridad
nara no tiene la autoridad para tomar
esas decisiones no tiene el derecho los
medios tampoco para tomar control de
esos documentos y esta es la ley
el presidente Disfruta de una ley sin
límites para tomar decisiones respecto
de la disposición de estos documentos
no tiene límites para tomar esa decisión
ni los archivistas ni el congreso tiene
autoridad de vetar la decisión del
presidente
el acta de registros presidenciales no
confiere
ninguna autoridad mandatoria ni siquiera
discrecional por parte de los
archivistas para clasificar estos
registros
bajo el estatuto de esta responsabilidad
queda solamente en manos del presidente
de los Estados Unidos piensen en eso esa
es la decisión piensen en eso
[Aplausos]
ahora piensen en eso
cualquier documento que el presidente
decida tomar con él Él tiene el derecho
de hacerlo es un derecho absoluto Y esta
es la ley
Y eso es algo que la gente ahora ha
visto y que no puede ser más claro Ellos
tienen que dejar este caso de inmediato
porque está destruyendo al país
[Música]
y por eso es que ningún otro presidente
incluyendo aquellos que se quedaron con
muchos más documentos que yo ninguno ha
sido si quiere investigado mucho menos
acusado por un crimen
porque esta declaratoria falsa da a
conocer por la administración de Belén
que incluye fotografías de cajas mucha
gente me ha preguntado Por qué tenía
estas cajas porque quería estas cajas la
respuesta sumada con tener cada o todos
los derechos bajo esta acta de registro
presidenciales es que estas cajas
contenían todo tipo de pertenencias
presidencial muchas cosas camisas
zapatos de todo
como puede ser visto en la foto donde
alguien que no soy yo me pregunto quién
pudo haber sido
dejó caer una de estas cajas que estaba
bien acomodada cayó en el piso
se cayeron periódicos cortes de prensa
miles y miles de fotos de la Casa Blanca
El fotógrafo de la Casa Blanca algunos
están aquí hoy ellos tomaron muchísimas
fotos y Las guardamos todas estaban en
esas cajas
ropas recuerdos muchas muchas más cosas
yo no había tenido la posibilidad de
revisar todas esas cajas es un trabajo
largo y tedioso que toma muchísimo
tiempo y yo estaba preparado para
hacerlo Pero tengo una vida muy ocupada
he tenido una vida muy ocupada y ellos
lo hacen cada vez más ocupado porque
cada vez pelean más
y bajo esta decisión de medias de shocks
pareciera no haber ningún afán yo no
tenía ninguna fan Porque esa decisión
era legal
la otra imagen que fue viral ustedes se
acuerdan de esa cuando estaba bueno
enojado y corrupto Esa foto es edificada
por el FBI estaban en mara lago
ellos estaban ubicando documentos en
todo el piso se acuerdan de esa foto
famosa estaban en todo el piso decían
confidencial decía presidencial todo
tipo de cosas
y se suponía que iban a estar ahí
bueno en un estado Así cuando lo
pusieron ellos lo organizaron pusieron
la foto y lo liberaron ilegalmente a la
prensa tomaron mis registros médicos mi
pasaporte mi certificado de nacimiento y
se disculparon incluso trajeron una
profesional que debía abrir
cajas de seguridad saben que encontrar
no encontraron nada No había nada No
había nada ahí
de acuerdo con el acta de registro
presidenciales que fue muy importante se
suponía que yo debía negociar con nara
exactamente lo que estaba haciendo hasta
que ocurrió lo de mar al lago y el
asalto por parte de agentes del FBI yo
tengo cintas de seguridad Y les di a
ellos las citas de seguridad de todo
y era una violación flagrante desde la
cuarta enmienda de la Constitución que
protege el derecho
ante la búsqueda registro y razonable
y Sebastián usted cubrió eso muy bien
debo decirlo muy bien
Yo no soy quien cree que está por encima
de la ley yo soy el que sigue la ley Yo
soy el único
es Joe biden y su corto departamento de
injusticia ellos son los que creen que
está por encima de la ley nunca antes ha
habido dos estándares de justicia en el
país
no se han relevado de una manera tan
dramática Joe biden tenía montones de
documentos clasificados de su momento
como vicepresidente incluso de su
momento como senador
que era completamente y totalmente
ilegal de hechos otros senadores
escucharon de esto
y había que ver la respuesta de ellos no
hay manera eso era totalmente ilegal
como senador el señor
se sorprendieron muchísimo cuando
descubrieron porque pensaban que era
imposible de hacer
envió
1800 cajas a la universidad de Delaware
haciendo que esta búsqueda fuera mucho
más difícil para cualquiera y el se negó
a entregarlas y él se negó a dejar que
la gente observe los documentos y luego
dice cómo es que se comporta también
muchos de los documentos clasificados de
biden fueron estaban en Chinatown en
Washington lo sorprendente considerando
que su familia recibe tanto dinero por
parte de china me pregunto Cuántas veces
los amigos nuestros amigos de China
revisaron estos documentos en Chinatown
otros estaban inseguros en su supuesta
centro en Washington pagado por un
millón de dólares al año el dinero
supuestamente llega desde China y hay
otros documentos clasificados
que se vieron en todo el piso de su
garaje donde ahora se aloja su famoso
Corvette está tan orgulloso de ese carro
no había seguridad la puerta estaba
abierta la mayoría de las veces estaba
abierta todos esos documentos
clasificados todos esos documentos
estaban en el piso como si fueran basura
a diferencia de mí
que tenía una completa de clasificación
y una autoridad significativa con
presidente la vicepresidente yo voy de
no tenía autoridad para desclasificar ni
poseer esos documentos no tenía derecho
en vez de caer bajo la acta de registro
presidencia de las acciones de biden
cayeron bajo otra acta de registros
federales que es mucho más agresiva en
términos de penalidades criminales y no
le del torcido de biden han sabido algo
de esa búsqueda no no han sabido de eso
solamente de la mía de mucho más infame
que cualquier otro
Hilary Clinton
estableció esta revisión falsa de un
servidor para divulgar esta información
para evitar que eso pasara
ocultarla a pagar por escandalos pagos
en la fundación Clinton lo que sea
Hilary se quedó con muchos documentos
clasificados con mucha información
sensible Bajo su servidor algunos de
ellos
resultaron filtrados En el computador de
Anthony Winner se acuerdan de ese
computador de Anthony Winner en su
computador ustedes no quieren estar en
su computador
todo era ilegal
porque afortunadamente ella nunca fue
presidente nunca tuvo el poder de de
clasificar nada
[Aplausos]
Muchas gracias ella no tenía el poder
para de clasificar es una gran
diferencia Joe tampoco